when you're fighting against status quo
ah it's tough but we are up for the
challenge and I believe that that's
where we should be and we have great
companies that are really excited to
working with us those are early adapters
and I I believe those will be the ones
and eventually
um bring more people and help the market
adjust to the new to the new apartment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Maya Huber an
entrepreneur occupational therapist and
an expert in career development she's an
HR thought leader with main expertise in
the fields of job analyst analysis and
the future of work and has gained more
than 15 years of practical and
theoretical research experience managing
HR companies focusing on the work
inclusion of marginalized population
groups she is a consultant to private
and governmental organizations for
recruiting processes and is passionate
about empowering businesses to create
successful recruiting processes
Maya Uber welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me how are
you thank you for having me it's
exciting I'm excited to dive into a
world we're going to look at talent and
human resources and people and in quite
an interesting Journey today you're the
co-founder and CEO of tatio formerly
skill set I'm excited to hear all about
that as well as a lot of your previous
um Endeavors which which were in really
interesting organizations so we'll dive
into that in just a little bit but tell
me a little bit about yourself and what
you really care about
uh so first of all thank you for having
me
um I wake up every morning uh with the
mission to stop uh the workforce
exclusion in the market so I'm doing
three years actually it's not just that
we just start it does didn't start with
tattoo
um but
um for years I was working I I come from
a jar I have a 15 years of experience in
that space and my co-founder and I uh
worked for 15 years
um with job Seekers across the board but
we have a extensive experience with
underprivileged populations
so through the years we've met a lot of
job Seekers that their resumes do not
qualified for a job
and we had a mission to make sure that
they funded our job and that their
employees are satisfied with their
performance
um so when you're doing that without a
resume sometimes without even
um
small professional experience in terms
of their experience in the world their
work history you need to find new ways
to connect People based on
um new metrics that are not words right
because resumes are based on words
so for this this is what we did and
um I will tell you a bit more about
tattoo and infinite but for me
um providing the the inequal opportunity
to end every person to find himself in
the world first is a mission and I'm
doing it for years just I love that okay
very cool so tell me a little bit about
tattoo and then we'll link it back to
your mission
perfect so uh tattoo is sourcing
technology we connect companies and job
Seekers based on competencies alone
so our deep technology is
um smart simulation tests that we create
pretty fast and adjust pair
um per positioning market and we Source
People based on through those simulation
have them engage in experiences that
represent the main core task of a job
we analyzed the performance online and
then we do the match based on that so
nowhere resumes no application form job
experiences candidates get more insight
about the job
um and show you know show to the show
the company what they're really worth
what are their competencies and then
we're doing the match uh at the end
where B2B companies and
um recorders work with us or HR teams
that work with us can reach
um a platform with updated pool as
qualified available and relevant
candidates ranked based on their
competencies alone
so it's blind recruiting focus on uh
competencies and that's where you get an
access to this untapped pool of job
Seekers and of course a more qualified
pool which eventually will resolve in a
better retention rate and high
engagement
um process through the the hiring
process
um
uh we work in the US we just raise our
seed route
and we our headquarters here
so let's talk a little bit about
competency-based hiring versus
traditional methods so what what are
sort of what what is you know maybe
paying me the landscape of you know what
are the considerations for you know what
what are you giving up and what are you
gaining here
so the traditional way we look at people
uh once we want to make sure they are
qualified for the job is based on the
stories they tell about themselves and
their work history right
so
um for years that means the process
actually for decades
and I think a lot of things change it's
not just covered a lot of things change
in the work for the at the last uh
decade and
I think we should all agree that your
work is really do not necessarily say
something about your skills and I give
you my own example if you look at Mario
resume uh four years ago I had 15 years
of experience in HR I had the pil the
phds which is privilege
um uh credential to show but no one will
look at my resume to be head of product
right is that relevant right I will not
cross any ATF system or HCM but I guess
no one willing to be
um and I'm qualified for a job right I
have a startup I'm I I I'm the one who
developed the product and and I think
when you look at the future of work
people are uh moving across Industries
changing careers
um and it's not just linear you know
people uh stop everything to be become
an Uber drivers in order to have some
money and to um focus on their art
whatever so we need to find new taxonomy
to uh to assess the candidates
um uh compatibilities and competencies
and you cannot learn that from words or
from stories because they do not tell
enough and you know the paper
can can have it all you can say whatever
you want in a questionnaire in in a form
doesn't really means what you're doing
what what you're able to do uh at the
end of your job so for me competencies
is testing people's skills within the
context of the job
it's just asking Michael are you do you
have a great Excel skills you can say
yes but it depends
on wide environment so you will need if
it will be a front line I don't know
um a desk representative with people
coming over the time asking questions
your ability to focus on your skills and
on your cell skills and Etc that will be
lower
so it really depends on on you and the
combination of the position itself and
how you can um reflect your skills at
the end
and how do you build then you know what
is the process of building the
competency process where where you
evaluate the candidate so how do you how
do you navigate through this new type of
environment in which you can assess
candidates because you have to hopefully
provide a better tool than than the
existing you know Millennia old tool of
looking at somebody's experience asking
them questions and then hopefully you
find the right match you're saying okay
let's flip that upside down
what is the process of sort of discover
of rediscovering this evaluation process
so there's a lot of evidence-based
comes from the market each market in the
world we are focusing in the U.S but
also in Israel and in Europe everything
everywhere there's this uh database that
represent the the main course tasks or
knowledge or experience that requires
per job this database is commonly held
but the the labor market are researchers
that went been uh going through for
years we take this database uh we did it
we did some analysis with it but at the
end those are deep job analysis is that
represent what and across the market
what a specific job requires
so we take those competencies or those
core tasks and then we reflect those in
simulation
I guess the data is there
and I want to I want to I wish that I
will be more solutions like us because
the data is there that will take this
database to the next step and not just
ask people about their competencies
rather than test them for the
competencies before the first interview
and then what what is sort of the user
experience on the other side from the
hiring perspective well what is the how
are you thinking through that experience
that you provide them
so first of all uh they they need to
learn to work with the new tool at the
end they they see a list of qualified
candidates and they walk through that
it's pretty easy so it's platform that
they know but the data is different so
it's you know I keep uh I keep
um noticing that HR personas finding
tough you know that this is what they do
for years they only watched resume over
over those decades so they need to to
learn to work with a new tool with a new
taxonomy
um
at a minute to see the simulation and
what we test because it's so search for
forward it's not popping balloons it's
not comparing Square it's not you know
it's not a complex deep questionnaire
that you don't understand what's behind
it it's straightforward they're doing
the job if you are a sales rep for
instance if you want to if you want
looking for a service rep you will see
people who
um receive the list of leads they
qualify those leads and they interact
with prospective customers in order to
sell them based on a piece they got so
that's the job
um and I think for both sides if we will
meet make it as much as we can closer to
the market
to the real
um uh requirements of the market and the
real environment at the end that's where
our prediction score will be of course
better and uh change
will be easier to adapt
awesome so so take me through the the
vision
of of what you're doing so you know
where how do you picture the world
through your Endeavor in in the eyes
that you want to see it so what is what
is the vision that you're bringing to
the employment evaluation HR world
so my dream is that my kids will not use
your resume or they will not have to use
resume as a as an opportunity to apply
for a job I wanted to be you know
something that will laugh that their
parents used to send by facts that is
all thing out of the thing that is out
of the world and for me
um competencies or this new paradigm of
testing People based on competencies
um we start from sourcing but I don't
want to stop there for me it's a new
taxonomy that should go with the uh with
people from
um from being a candidate to being an
employee to upscale and rescue through
the organization so imagine you did this
test or competency and once you applied
you have your Baseline and you know what
you need to train on and then the
company right after a year after two
years can offer you new opportunities
you experience those and
um and you will find your new path
um I hope that that will be our uh that
will be our future of work and uh you
know for me it's not just about making
things more efficient
is adapting to the new uh to the new
world where jobs are not the way they
were
right now that that I I completely get
that and I think that when you're
talking about the future of work and the
way that people are evaluated especially
in an environment in which you know the
the environment at least in our
ecosystem right it is encouraging people
to try out different things to switch
between roles this multidisciplinary
idea a lot of the rules that we have
didn't exist before right I mean some of
the roles that we have today in
companies and organizations they just
didn't even exist five years ago and so
it's I think that you know when we're
looking at the way that people would
evaluate
um Personalities in in the 50s is very
very different than how it is probably
today and and while the current method
is the same it should change and sounds
like what you're saying is is calling
for that change what is the resistance
that you've been meeting from different
aspects of make of bringing this Vision
to reality
um so first of all the great support
we've got is more from the job Seeker
side than the company's point of view
um and I I guess we can understand that
job Seeker are the one who are
frustrated by by you know the the old
matter then I think
people today want to be
um more involved in their decision
making and a better understanding of
their career path it's not about
clicking on a button sending your
resumes as much as you can and praying
for people to come to come back to you
um we do a resistance I'm not sure it's
resistant but you know you need to adapt
to a new change
um from the ahr teams so
um they're afraid that those tools be
will be
um and not and and another
um uh path to uh job Seekers so they
will need to do another assessment and
they will not engage in a process which
is actually wrong because it's uh at the
end is involved in um
higher engagement rate from the job
secretly they feel respectful and it's
fun and they love the fact that they are
you know that they have the power to
control their lives and to have a better
understanding what they're about to do
um
you know a salesperson that I met lately
told me that our biggest
um War we're we're fighting against
status quo
when you're fighting against status quo
uh it's tough uh but we are up for the
challenge and I believe that that's
where we should be and we have great
companies that are really excited
working with us those are early adapters
and I I believe those will be the ones
that eventually
um bring more people and uh help the
market adjust to the new to the new uh
Parliament
beautiful so I'm tying this back now to
right to the beginning and with my
favorite question for this whole series
which is why do you do what you do then
why do you spend these years now
and tatio I and then then
share whatever you like but you know
this it's a lot of years and it's a it's
a big commitment and it's a big push
it's a big Vision why do you do it
uh first of all I enjoy a lot but I
chose that
um for me it's really a mission it's
been a mission for years I now I I
engaged with technology to solve that
but I did it for years
um manually or you know by meeting uh
personas and uh not using Tech
I I feel like just thinking Justice have
to be made I feel like um you know we
cannot expect things to be changed while
doing the same things over and over
again
and and I think we should it's about
time
um post covered this uh recession in the
market and the fact that people want
different things
uh I think we should move forward and if
not
um we will have deep issues in the work
first that we will not be able to solve
in the future
there's a hidden tunnel pool that should
be engaged
um
um and I think this is the only way to
go
I I completely agree I um I love it and
I wish you best of luck as you scale
this as you improve the product as you
bring this to the market to even more
and as you make those transitions that
you mentioned before at the end
um you know a lot of people talk about
the future of work but I think that it's
really it's it's what's really
interesting is that it's not just about
the future of work in the actual office
but it's the future of how we actually
get to the work right and I think that's
dealing with so thank you very very much
my I really appreciate your time and
your your energy I know how busy you are
so I'm gonna let you go but thank you
very much
thank you so much it was great talking
to you thank you